[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS HOOD: Hello, everyone.
You are listening to the
value of APIs in Innovation.
Hopefully everyone's
in the right place
and everyone's
having a great day.
My name is Chris Hood.
I am with the Global Customer
Success Team for Apigee,
which is part of Google Cloud.
And before we dive into
today's topic on innovation,
I wanted to give
everyone the opportunity
to jot down my email address.
If you have questions
or if you would
like to discuss
Apigee in more detail,
want to talk about your
API program, please just
send me a message.
We are going to have a
little time at the end
to ask questions.
And for those who I don't
get to, then, again,
here's a great way that we
can follow up and talk more
about innovation, and
APIs, and all things
that we like to talk about.
So while I was thinking
about today's topic,
I couldn't help but think
about the opportunities
in front of each of us.
And I'm sure most of
you who are listening,
and probably one of the
reasons why you're here,
is because of an
opportunity that you
have to create, transform,
or even grow your business.
And hopefully,
after this, you'll
be excited to go off and develop
incredible new digital journeys
and innovate new ideas
for your customers.
Innovation is a great topic.
It is often seen as a
driver for competitiveness
or as a differentiator across
your products, processes,
and people.
And this is even more true in
an era of intense competition
and continuous change, where
the longevity of our products
have been decreasing,
and automation
has become essential.
And more importantly,
customers have higher demands.
But how do we keep up?
How do we innovate in a way
that is adaptive, continuous,
and meaningful?
One thing I share with customers
when discussing innovation
is this.
Believing you know what
your customers want
more than they do will
cost you those customers.
And here are some stats
that demonstrate this.
Today, customers
are more curious.
Customers visit new brands,
research, read reviews,
and price match multiple times
before making a purchase.
In fact, 49% of
digital consumers
research a brand or
product two to four times
before converting.
Customers are also more
impatient than ever before.
At Google, we've found that
51% of digital consumers
don't believe companies
meet their expectations,
and 53% of visits are abandoned
if the mobile experience takes
longer than three
seconds to load.
But the real eye opener
is what consumers
will do after poor experiences.
92% of digital
consumers say they
would stop purchasing
from a company
after three or fewer
poor experiences.
And customers are also
more demanding today.
And here's the important stat.
Digital consumers are
looking for companies
that are innovative.
56% of digital
consumers actively
seek to buy from the most
innovative companies,
the companies that align with
their own technical profile
or their digital
persona and enterprises
that try to impress them with
personalized experiences.
Today, 66% of
digital consumers say
it takes more to impress
them than ever before,
and 65% expect
personalized experiences.
If we return to my
quote just a moment ago,
believing you know what
your customers want
more than they do, here's
the stat you must remember.
76% of consumers expect
companies to know their needs
before asking them.
But how do we accomplish this?
How do we innovate
at speed and scale
to meet the demands
of customers?
In 2019-- that's today, folks--
APIs are everywhere.
Mobile phones, when you checked
your email, weather reports,
ordering an Uber, even when
you turned on today's webcast,
you were using an API.
More importantly, APIs
are powering innovation.
Companies using APIs
as a differentiator
and a competitive
advantage are winning.
Take a look at something
like Uber Eats or Postmates.
We have one application that
uses restaurant and menu
APIs, driver and delivery
APIs, payment APIs, all
in one seamless experience.
From an enterprise
point of view,
APIs are essential for
creating innovative business
models and innovative modes
of engagement with customers.
APIs have helped many businesses
meet customers' increasing
expectations for
connected experiences,
but they've also helped
some enterprises pursue
even bigger or more profound
business evolutions,
things such as unlocking new
revenue streams and product
categories, creating
online marketplaces,
executing platform
business models,
and even many of the
other things you'll
find in those much
loftier definitions
of digital transformation.
Over the years, we've seen
this evolution happen.
APIs started as a way
to improve access.
REST as an alternative
to SOAP, HTTP
verbs with much
simpler architectures.
We moved into an
integration model.
Systems or software A connected
to system or software B,
sending and receiving data
between cloud systems.
And today, many businesses
are still in this mindset.
As enterprises have
become more mature,
they reach an experienced view
of APIs, mobile apps powered
by APIs that deliver
experiences to their customers,
like mobile check
deposits for your bank
or a loyalty rewards and payment
system for your favorite coffee
orders.
But the enterprises that
truly unlock the power of APIs
reach this transformational
level, digital transformation
of the enterprise itself,
innovation, new revenue models,
improved partnerships, and
increased modes of engagement.
From a long-standing
integration technology
to being a powerful
agent of transformation,
the evolution of APIs has
been impressive and exciting.
Today, APIs are the
fundamental building blocks
for successful businesses.
Yes, APIs.
And for those of you who
don't know what an APIs is--
Application
Programming Interfaces.
programming interfaces
are helping companies
create the differentiators
for their products,
processes, and people.
APIs are helping companies
innovate every day
to build new
connected experiences,
become more agile for customers,
and open up new business
markets to collaborate
with partners
and monetize their
digital assets.
APIs are super powerful.
But you know what?
The more I actually
think about it,
I personally don't agree
with this definition of APIs
anymore.
Application
programming interface--
it sounds way too technical.
And honestly, it doesn't
capture the essence
of meaningful and
continuous innovation
that we are talking about today.
Maybe it's time for us to
actually innovate the API.
If we are truly looking at
APIs to help drive our business
forward while also innovating
across products, processes,
and people, we should
probably start looking
at APIs in a different way.
What if we change
things up a little bit?
Here's an option--
application product interface.
Being able to build products
in new digital experiences
is essential for business today.
A few weeks ago, I was having
this discussion on LinkedIn
with a group, and
the comment was
made that ignoring application
integration scenarios
means ignoring 98% of the
scenarios where APIs are
used in the real world today.
Well, my response aligns with
how today's smart enterprises
need to think about APIs.
I stated, no matter
what the integration is,
at the start of an API's life
is a value proposition that must
result in a business outcome.
Otherwise, you wouldn't need the
integration in the first place.
This is a complete
mindset shift.
APIs are not just
about integration.
APIs must be treated as
products no different
than any other
product you design,
build, or manage in
your organization.
When you design
API products, you
should ask questions like what
problems do my users face?
How do I make the API
product easy to consume?
Do I start designing
API products
for an internal audience
or just jump right
into an external audience?
Can proxies be reused in
multiple API products?
How can I measure the
impact of my API products?
The answers to these questions
will form your API product
strategy, and the strategy
must support your business.
And you can manage your APIs,
as we were just talking about,
like other products
in your organization
with its own product lifecycle.
Design your APIs from an
outside-in perspective.
Document them so application
developers can innovate faster.
Market your APIs to
attract new opportunities,
allowing others to
help you innovate.
And of course,
analyze what works
and what doesn't work so that
you can iterate on your APIs.
And if you want to
get really crazy,
find ways to monetize
your new API products.
There are numerous approaches,
such as revenue sharing,
fee-based models,
or even freemium,
allowing API consumers to play
with your APIs in a sandbox
before subscribing.
Today, in hundreds of
organizations globally,
APIs have become the business.
A great example
for monetization is
with AccuWeather, a global
leader in weather data.
AccuWeather wanted an easy way
to attract developers, monetize
data via flexible pricing plans,
and offer a seamless experience
that provides
customers the potential
to build the next big thing.
Within the first two
months of going live
on the Apigee platform, nearly
2,500 experienced developers
paid for and accessed
APIs to innovate
new weather-based applications.
And as of today, AccuWeather is
processing over 30 billion API
requests per day.
Another example
of monetization is
with Swisscom, the
leading telecommunications
provider in Switzerland,
providing phone, internet,
and other services for
millions of customers.
Swisscom established
an API program
using Apigee to bridge
its network and resources
to outside apps and products.
As a result of their focus on
productization of their APIs,
Swisscom generates
millions in revenue
solely through their
Apigee API program.
But maybe we can look
at APIs another way.
How about application
process interface?
Streamlining innovation by
using a platform like Apigee
with tools that allows your
company to be more nimble
might be a good way to
look at the value of APIs.
Most companies are faced
with this challenge.
The rate of change and
updates at the ESP layer
and systems of records is
very slow, taking months
or longer to update back-end
systems to support customer
demands, while at the
top, your customers
expect those new digital
experiences to be
available in days or sooner.
Apigee Edge can balance
the pace of change
between your back-end systems
and your front-end digital
experiences.
Within one platform,
your business
can now quickly scale,
manage, analyze, and secure
APIs and data
connections in order
to focus more on the connected
digital experiences that
are going to drive
your business growth.
Another way to
streamline processes
is to look at a basic
CI/CD workflow, Continuous
Integration and
Continuous Delivery.
These processes will help your
organization fluidly innovate,
while maintaining internal
governance and adoption
across your entire business.
Your APIs can flow
through this process,
allowing your API consumers
to develop new experiences
and innovate faster,
while also helping
deliver new connected
experiences to market faster,
which, if you remember from
our statistics earlier,
will directly help you keep
up with the expectations
of your customers
and keep them happy.
And don't forget that
enterprises can drastically
accelerate app development by
seamlessly leveraging cloud
services to reduce
development time,
improve security,
reach new markets,
and be more flexible to
the changing consumer
demands and markets.
The real hidden benefit
of app modernization
with API management in the
cloud is that an organization
is now strategically
positioned to lift and shift
workloads or take advantage
of service offerings
from cloud providers based on
regional availability, cost,
quality of services, or the
relative superiority of one
cloud versus another
in terms of delivering
a specific capability
that you might need.
This process interface helps
to accelerate time to market,
increases the overall
consumption and standardization
of your data throughout
your organization,
and greatly decreases the
chance for your business
to be disrupted.
These are each the very
definition of open innovation.
And here's a great
example of a company that
has sustained the test
of time while evolving
their business using APIs.
Pitney Bowes, a
100-year-old company
that is best known
for postage meters
discovered that
leveraging Apigee,
they were able to reduce
their time to market
for new application development
from 18 months to 4 months.
As a result, Pitney
Bowes looks at APIs
as an entirely new
line of business.
Continuous process
improvement using APIs
was their innovation.
A more recent company,
cars.com, took the same approach
to modernizing their
application development.
By enabling
self-service onboarding
and reporting tools
for business users,
cars.com was able to speed
up their sellers' success
and improve the overall
visibility into API calls
for policies around rate
limiting, throttling,
and security.
Their focus on
process interfaces
has helped grow their
API program by over 125%.
How about we look at
APIs one more way--
application people interface.
Strong businesses
link every decision
back to improving their
value propositions.
And in my experience, APIs
deliver the most value
when serving as an interface
between a company and people.
From digital marketplaces
and content platforms
to smart homes and
wearable devices,
across virtually all industries,
connected experiences
are redefining how customers
interact with businesses
and how businesses must
engage with customers.
And here is another stat that
speaks to your need for APIs.
By 2020, connected experiences
will overtake price and product
as the key brand differentiator,
and 86% of buyers
will pay more for
that experience.
APIs can no longer
be a technology play.
You must leverage APIs
to connect with people.
API design from an
API-first mindset
begins with your customers.
Typically, businesses
look at APIs as a means
by which to expose the data
on their back-end systems
out to their customers.
This is called an
inside-out perspective.
When enterprises focus solely
on integration or exposing data
from the inside
out, they completely
miss the opportunities
to innovate
new connected experiences
for their customers.
Apigee helps you
design and deploy APIs
from an outside-in perspective.
This approach focuses
on the customer's view
of your business
first, leveraging
their digital persona for
engaging with your products
and services and
enabling you to create
connected experiences
that resonate
with their expectations.
Those experiences are built
by app developers or consumers
of your API products,
built by your API team,
and that didn't touch
your back end systems--
outside in.
Beginning with a
digital persona,
you can map new experiences
with an outside-in perspective.
If done right,
this exercise helps
bring business and technology
stakeholders together
to understand what
connected experiences need
to be developed, what APIs
need to be available to make
those experiences a
reality, and if the back end
systems need to be updated
to support the new products
and services.
Apigee and APIs can help
you seamlessly accelerate
your innovation process.
Application people
interfaces allow
enterprises to express
parts of their business
as digital experiences.
When someone orders a movie
ticket via a voice assistant,
that transaction
is only possible
because the voice
assistant can call
an API that expresses
capabilities such as showtime
look up or location search
and transaction approvals.
Regardless of whether
a developer is
familiar with the
underlying technology,
businesses leverage
APIs to connect people
to their technology,
and the product
that the customers care about
becomes those experiences.
Because ultimately, if
your customers are happy,
you will grow your business.
Or to simplify this
formula, happy customers
equals organizational value.
Consider a company
like Autodesk.
Their entire goal was to
build APIs that were tailored
to their customers' needs.
Through the Apigee
platform, they
were able to boost their
customer engagement
by three times, while
also improving time
to deployment by 87%.
The company relentlessly looks
at the ever-changing demands
of people and quickly innovates
new technologies with APIs
to keep up with those demands.
Another example is with Philips,
a global technology company
that developed a smart
lighting platform
for their Hue connected
lights fully controlled
by a smartphone app with APIs.
Phillips took the approach
to let their engineers focus
on product development and
new digital experiences
rather than managing
technical integrations.
This customer-centric
management of their APIs
now supports over 25 million
lighting requests daily.
Their goal was simple.
Interface their
business with people.
In each of these
examples, the key
is to understand that
innovation does not
need to be revolutionary.
You must learn how to
fail faster, then iterate
so you can innovate sooner.
When you return to your
work, find the opportunities
that allow your organization
to evolve, to quickly
work on new ideas to keep up
with your changing markets,
and to iterate
towards innovation.
Apigee as a leader and full
lifecycle API management.
This is our fourth year in a row
that we've been named a leader,
and Gartner has positioned
Apigee overall highest
for our ability to
execute your API vision.
And more than 700 enterprises
are using Apigee today
to build API programs
that generate new business
opportunities and help
innovate new experiences
for their customers.
If you have specific
questions about how
APIs are being used in an
industry or just in general,
as I said earlier,
please reach out to me.
I'm happy to talk
to you about it.
And finally, I wanted
to share with you
a tool we have called Compass.
Apigee Compass is
an assessment tool
that measures your company's
digital maturity across 10
dimensions.
After the webcast, head
over to compass.apigee.com,
or you can do a Google
search for Apigee Compass.
We have 10 questions,
10 dimensions,
and you can do it
in about 10 minutes.
And when you have your
score, share it with me.
I'd love to see where you're at.
Let's open it up
for some questions.
I see some questions
coming in-- looks good.
Ooh, lots of good
questions here.
Let's see.
Will this deck be
available later?
Yes, absolutely.
We are recording this.
I believe we will have it
available in a video format
and posted on YouTube.
We'll get the link
out, share it,
and then you can share it with
your colleagues, coworkers,
or anybody else.
OK, let's see.
I agree with your points.
But every time I bring up the
value of APIs to my CEO or CIO,
they tell me that
APIs are for software,
so go talk with the
technology teams.
How do I convince
them that APIs are
about more than integrations?
It's a great question.
Actually, I would say that
this is exactly why we
put this presentation together.
I would start off by saying,
look, application product
interfaces, application process
interfaces, application people
interfaces, whatever one
kind of resonates well
with you is probably going to
resonate well with your CEO.
Start by explaining
that APIs really
are about more than
integrations and that you
want to talk to them or discuss
with them how they can help
drive the business forward, not
just work on technology pieces.
I think if you leverage
some of the things
that we've talked
about today and, again,
focus a lot on say the
people connectivity
and being able to meet the
demands of the consumers, that
will be a good starting point
for you in terms of how you
sell this internally and get
it going up to your CEO level
or executives that care more
about the business piece, OK?
Let's see, what else?
You mentioned APIs can help
us get to market faster.
But our security
team always holds up
our innovation opportunities.
What can we tell
security in order
to prevent them from
blocking innovation?
Yeah, that's a good question.
If you go back into the
presentation, a moment ago,
we were talking a little
bit about process interface.
And believe it or not,
a lot of the things
that we have built into
Apigee as a platform,
including things
like rate limiting,
and OAuth, and some security
features, a lot of the policies
are there in a way
so that you don't
have to jeopardize security
at the cost of trying
to innovate more.
You should be able to do both.
In fact, all of these
companies and the references
that I've shared with
you today, they all
have the same type of problems.
You have a security team.
You have governance regulations.
Your pipeline for
your lifecycles
all have this structure
in it, and you're
trying to kind of
break free of that
so you can do new and
cool and exciting things.
You've got to be
able to leverage
some of those policies
that are already in place
so that you can standardize on
security best practices that,
again, open you
up to innovation.
Also, the platform in general
allows you to do things
like mocking API responses.
So now, you don't
really need security
because they're not actually
touching the back end.
Your mocking of APIs
can be used just
to share with other
partners, share
throughout your ecosystem.
And maybe you can
innovate that way,
and then, once you
have something, then
you can start talking
about how do you
reuse the policies that
are in place to more secure
those APIs.
Possibly.
It's a good question.
Email me and we can talk a
little bit more about that
specifically.
Let's see.
I find the thought of
monetizing APIs interesting,
but you're talking about
monetizing the experiences
consumers have, not really
the integration pieces, right?
Well, what I am talking
about is actually
monetizing the API itself.
So let's say you've got an
API that does a look-up to all
of your locations.
So for a retail
store, this might not
make sense because in retail,
you want people to find you,
so all of that location data
is probably already published
out there.
We can look for it
on Google right.
My favorite store
closest location to me,
and that's going to be there.
But when we look
at other data, that
might be very valuable
to your organization.
If we take an example
of AccuWeather
that is a master at
monetizing their data,
they've got weather
forecasting information.
And they can then sell the
actual transaction of that API.
And they've packaged it
in a way so that consumers
can come in, buy packages
of data that they want,
and then go off and develop
new applications on behalf
of AccuWeather.
So there's hundreds of
applications out there.
And all of those applications
are using the APIs
that AccuWeather has published.
And those developers are
paying for that access.
So when we talk about
monetizing your API products,
we are actually looking
at ways that you can
monetize the APIs themselves.
And what that
ultimately will do is
open up new lines
of business for you.
It's an entirely
new revenue stream
that is now coming in that you
can add to your bottom line.
That's the key.
Let's see, a couple
more, and then we're
going to be out of time.
Connecting people to technology
really makes sense today,
but our software engineers
don't see it that way.
Like in the Pitneys
example, how do you
get engineers to change
their view of APIs?
Another great question.
So there is a
challenge, I think,
for a lot of
organizations to begin
getting this adoption of
how do we look at APIs?
It takes a lot to transition
from looking at APIs
as application
programming interfaces,
where we clearly
know that these are
ways to integrate systems,
and integrate software,
and to speed up the
development process of building
applications.
And I think if you go to,
really, any engineering
department, they're going
to say, yeah, we have APIs,
and, yeah, we develop new
APIs, and that's great.
But when you begin to focus on
a different perspective of that,
when you start looking from
this outside-in perspective
and saying, what do
our customers want?
And then I'm going
to build an API that
delivers what they want.
And I'm only going to
connect that to the back end
when it makes sense.
Now, you're starting
to shift that mindset.
And it is hard.
It's very hard to
completely change
how engineers look at APIs.
But once again, I think the
context of this entire webcast
was to paint APIs in a different
way so that you can take that,
and you can go off, and you can
say, look, we want to innovate,
and we want to look at
APIs differently so that we
can achieve these really
interesting and exciting things
that we know our
customers are asking for.
That's the key.
And maybe it starts by
actually having a meeting where
you bring together your business
teams and your technology
teams, and you outline
what that vision is.
And as you come together
as a cohesive view of APIs,
then I think you're going
to be able to get to where
Pitney Bowes is at, OK?
Let's see, we'll get
one more in here.
Do you see APIs being
used differently
in different industries?
No.
[LAUGHS] Yeah, it's an
interesting question.
But the reality is, I think
at the end of the day,
I share with people and
I share with customers
this simple idea.
Do you have customers?
I think in every single
situation, whether you're B2C,
or even if you're B2B--
those B2B situations,
the other businesses
are still your customers--
everybody has
customers, and everybody
is trying to meet the
demands of those customers.
So they're all using
APIs in a way that
allows them to accelerate
their development,
build new things, again,
reach markets faster, all
of these things we've
been talking about today.
But ultimately, it's
in a way that you can
meet the demands of customers.
And since everybody
has customers,
all of the industries
are basically
just applying the
API philosophies
to meet the needs of their
customers differently.
But again, I guess,
at the end of the day,
it's really not that different.
I want to develop something,
and I want to research it,
and I want to give
it to my customers,
and I want to analyze it.
I have KPIs.
I have internal goals.
I want to meet those goals.
I want to grow my
business, right?
I think it doesn't really
matter what industry you're in.
You're all going to be trying
to accomplish the same thing,
and you're all looking
for ways to innovate.
And as I've said, APIs
bring a lot of value
to your ability to innovate.
And I think that's
a great way to end.
Once again, thank you
all for listening.
I appreciate the time.
And as I mentioned, you've
got my email address.
Once more, I'm Chris Hood.
I'm with Apigee,
part of Google Cloud.
You can reach me at
chrishood@google.com.
Free to email me and
let me know if there's
anything I can help you with.
Thank you again.
Have a great day.
[MUSIC PLAYING]